waren es vielleicht doch aliens ein
forschungsteam aus harvard hat jetzt
widerlegt dass es sich beim
interstellaren besucher um uhr um einen
stickstoff eisberg handeln doch genau
das war die bislang stärkste erklärung
für einen natürlichen ursprung uhr mesz
handelt es sich bei diesem mysteriösen
objekt also doch um ein außerirdisches
artefakt zum science in future.de bis
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert dekanat und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's
herzlich willkommen fest steht es
handelt sich um das erste interstellare
objekt in unserem sonnensystem dass wir
aufspüren konnten also das erste objekt
das von außerhalb aus dem interstellaren
raum durch unser sonnensystem flug
bekannt ist es also mon amour doch
wissenschaftlich erklärt werden kann es
bis heute nicht dabei fand sein
durchflug bereits im herbst vor vier
jahren 2017 statt seitdem diskutieren
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weltweit kontrovers über die natur das
mysteriöse objekt zwei us
wissenschaftler hatten erst anfang
diesen jahres 2021 die hypothese
aufgestellt dass es sich um einen teil
eines pluto artigen planeten eines
fernen planeten systems handeln könnte
demnach könnte obama ein fragment der
planeten küste seien und somit aus
festem stickstoff bestehen ein
interstellarer stickstoff eisberg also
anders sieht das dagegen der renommierte
harvard astrophysiker eppelheim kurzawa
er ist sich sicher und das schon seit
langer zeit dass hinter dem mysteriösen
objekt eine technologie von
außerirdischen steckt jetzt setzt er
noch einen drauf und widerlegt mit
seinem team die hypothese dass humor 1
stickstoff eisberg eines extrasolare
bluetooth ist wie genau kommt er dazu
und welche belege hat er alles zu dem
großen und spannenden rätselraten um
humor gibt es jetzt hier bei pixum seitz
in future der renommierte astrophysiker
wie loeb ist sich ganz sicher um humor
hat keinen natürlichen ursprung bei uns
im exklusiv-interview konnte er diese
these
ich halte ich begründen anders als viele
seiner kolleginnen und kollegen ist er
fest davon überzeugt dass es sich
keineswegs um einen kometen oder
asteroiden handelt dazu sagte löw in
einem interview mit dem redaktions
netzwerk deutschland das problem ist
dass obama keinen kometenschweif hatte
normalerweise wenn sich kometen der
sonne nähern verdampft ihre eishöhle und
es bildet sich ein schweif im fall von
oben mohamud konnten teleskope
allerdings keinen entdecken dann hieß es
na gut vielleicht ist es ein stein ohne
eis das problem damit ist dass das
objekt von der sonne weg beschleunigte
und mit einer zusätzlichen kraft
angetrieben wurde die in etwa mit dem
quadrat der entfernung von der sonne
abnahmen etwas das normalerweise durch
einen schweif erzeugt werden kann aber
den gab es ja nicht außerdem war die
geometrie des objekts extrem und es gab
weitere anomalien alles in allem waren
wir nur etwas das wir noch nie zuvor
gesehen hatten wie loeb bleibt also
dabei es muss sich um ein konstrukt von
außerirdischen gehandelt haben nur diese
theorie kann seiner meinung nach sowohl
die bahn als auch die form des objekts
erklärt in seinem buch extraterrestrial
first seien auf intelligent life beyond
es geht eher näher auf seine ideen ein
er beschreibt das mysteriöse objekt als
ein außerirdisches raumschiff das nach
dem prinzip eines sonnensegels durch den
interstellaren raum zu uns gereist kam
dabei stützt er sich vor allem auf die
beschleunigung des objekts und die
ungewöhnliche form beides kann seiner
meinung nach nur damit erklärt werden
dass es sich bei ihm um ein
außerirdisches raumschiff handelt dazu
sagte er in einem interview mit dem
redaktions netzwerk deutschland wenn die
einzige möglichkeit die fakten über
obama zu erklären darin besteht sich
etwas vorzustellen dass wir noch nie
gesehen haben warum nicht über einen
künstlichen ursprung nachdenken ich habe
ein segel vorgeschlagen das licht
reflektiert genau wie ein segel auf
einem boot das durch die reflektion von
luftpartikel angeschoben wird zudem
bezieht sich aber auf die äußere gestalt
des objektes da die auflösung der
teleskop bilder sehr gering ist gibt es
kein foto von humor doch die fachwelt
hatte vor vier jahren festgestellt dass
die helligkeit des objektes etwa in
einem takt von 8 stunden schwank daraus
schließen die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler dass humor rotiert die
helligkeit kurve lässt zudem auf die 3d
form schließen und diese ist anders als
alles andere was man bisher aus dem
sonnensystem kennt demnach muss das
interstellare objektiv form einer
zigarre oder aber einer scheibe haben
und zudem mindestens fünfmal so lang wie
breit sein und da sind wir auch gleich
bei dem großen problem der fachleute
denn wie soll solch eine spektakuläre
form auf natürliche art und weise
entstanden sein mindestens ebenso
spektakulär ist die bahn des objekts und
bei dem vorbeiflug an der sonne war es
wohl nicht nur ihre schwerkraft die auf
oben horror eingewirkt hat nach ansicht
der fachleute muss eine weitere kraft am
start gewesen sein doch was für eine es
gab die idee dass sich hinter um humor
ein gigantischer eisberg aus wasserstoff
verbirgt denn wasserstoff ist für
infrarot kameras nicht sichtbar doch das
wäre ja wohl bei seiner reise durch das
all verdampft eine andere idee uhr mon
amour als eine art staubwolke mit einer
100 mal geringeren dichte als luft doch
auch ein solches objekt wäre auf seiner
langen reise wohl schnell zerstört
worden im märz diesen jahres 2021 nahm
die kontroverse dann weiter an fahrt auf
ein us forschungsteam um den
astrophysiker stephen des und den
astronomen alan jackson hatte die
bisherigen beobachtungsdaten zu humor
noch einmal genauer ins visier genommen
die beiden wissenschaftler kamen somit
zu dem schluss dass es sich bei dem
objekt um ein fragment eines blutigen
exoplaneten gehandelt haben muss humor
moore bestünde demnach aus festem
stickstoff in der studie heißt es dieses
fragment wurde vermutlich durch einen
einschlag vor etwa einer halben
milliarde jahren aus der oberfläche in
dieses planeten herausgeschlagen und aus
seinem planetensystem hinauskatapultiert
seine flache form könnte das mysteriöse
objekt demnach erst bei seiner
annäherung an die sonne erhalten haben
als es um mehr als 95 prozent seiner
einzigen masse verlor nach ansicht der
beiden us forscher zeigt deutliche
unterschiede zu einem gewöhnlichen
kometen dazu schreiben sie das objekt
mit einer leicht geringeren
geschwindigkeit in unser sonnensystem
ein als erwartet das liegt nahe dass es
nicht länger als eine milliarde jahre
durch den interstellaren raum bereist
ist auch seine pfannkuchen artige form
unterscheidet es von allen anderen
bislang bekannten objekten in unserem
sonnensystem den beobachteten
raketenartigen schub erhielt das objekt
dann von der sonne die das stickstoff
eis auf schmolz und die dabei
entstehenden gase dem objekt einen schub
versetzten schon damals hatte der
astrophysiker philipp einspruch
eingelegt damals hatte er in einem
interview mit grenz wissenschaft aktuell
wie gesagt wenn humor aus stickstoff
bestanden hätte so sollte es auch spuren
von kohlenstoff beinhaltet haben wie sie
mit dem weltraumteleskop spitzer hätten
entdeckt werden können das war aber
nicht der fall und es ist sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass ein objekt aus
reinem stickstoff besteht auch sein
kollege der us-wissenschaftler amüsiere
astrophysiker von der harvard university
äußerte sich skeptisch gegenüber der
stickstoff aus ried hypothese denn
rainer stickstoff sei ihm als selten und
wurde bislang nur auf pluto aufgespürt
wo er nur knapp 0,5 prozent der
gesamtmasse ausmacht heißt also im
klartext niemals gäbe es genügend
stickstoff um solch ein gigantisches
objekt wie moore herzustellen nun hat
der forscher sich gemeinsam mit philipp
die stickstoff at these noch einmal
genauer angeschaut und die ergebnisse in
einem online fachartikel veröffentlicht
hier zeigen die beiden wissenschaftler
erneut dass es dafür in unserer galaxie
zu wenig exotisch gibt die beiden
verfechter dieser hypothese tesch und
jackson hatten im märz 2021 vorgerechnet
dass ein schläger auf einem solchen exo
pluto rund eine billion solche objekte
in den interstellaren raum katapultieren
könnten davon würden demnach etwa die
hälfte aus wassereis und stickstoff eis
bestehen sie waren sicher dass diese
objekt population ausreichen könnten um
die entdeckung und eigenschaften und
auch den rätselhaften schub von humor
hinreichend zu erklären doch der
astrophysiker
widerspricht dem wm in demnach müssten
überhaupt erst einmal ausreichend exodus
existieren doch diese annahme ist
bislang noch nicht bestätigt die große
frage also ist genügend stellaris
material vorhanden um das modell des
stickstoff eisbergs zu stützen dazu
äußern sich loeb und sein kollege
folgendermaßen unsere berechnung hierfür
sind sehr klar und einfach wir nutzen
alle parameter des stickstoff modells
mit denen das vorhandensein von uno
mutigen objekten und die entdeckung von
humor in unserem sonnensystem erklärt
werden könnte so wie die grundlegend
bekannten fakten über sterne in unserer
milchstraße
anhand der sich daraus ableitenden werte
können wir die gesamtmasse der solaren
beziehungsweise stellaren metall i tät
ableiten die zur extra flute umgewandelt
werden müsste damit die hypothese des
stickstoff modells plausibel wird doch
die analyse der wissenschaftler legt dar
dass die notwendige masse um mehrere
größenordnungen verfehlt wird heißt also
dass ein sternensystem nicht über
genügend stickstoff verfügen kann als
dass ich dort eine population an extra
blutes bilden kann demnach zeigt die
statistik dass es nicht genügend
interstellare objekte geben kann die aus
stickstoff bestehen um nur
wissenschaftlich sauber erklären zu
können dazu sagt avi lübz kollege amisia
das hauptproblem des modells eines
stickstoff eisbergs ist das dass es zur
entstehung einer ausreichenden
publikation solcher objekte mehr als das
zehnfache der gesamten sternen masse
unserer galaxie benötigen würde um
schlussendlich ausreichend exemplars
entstehen zu lassen die es braucht um
humor zu erklären wenn wir dann auch
noch die unausweichliche kosmische
erosion der angenommenen stickstoff
eisberge mit einbeziehen brauchen wir
sogar das tausendfache den gesamten
stellaren masse der milchstraße und auch
andere wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler zweifeln an der
stickstoff asteroiden hypothese und
haben ihre gedanken dazu ebenfalls
aufgeschrieben zu finden im fachjournal
butter auf seine marken astronomical
society prs
genauso wie er wie loeb kommen die vier
forscher zu dem schluss dass es zu
wenige stickstoff asteroiden geben kann
um damit um humor zu erklären heißt das
also jetzt dass albrecht hatte und es
sich beim horror tatsächlich um ein
außerirdisches artefakt handelt das ist
und bleibt die große frage denn
andererseits gibt es ausschließlich
diese beobachtungen kein bild und kein
beweis allerdings wurde nun die stärkste
hypothese für eine natürliche erklärung
des objekts widerlegt heißt also im
umkehrschluss das rätsel um humor geht
weiter die indizien sprechen wie da er
für ein künstliches von außerirdischen
gebautes objekt die fachwelt setzt jetzt
vor allem auf zukünftige moratti objekte
die hoffentlich früher entdeckt und dann
noch genauer und besser untersucht
werden können harvard-professor wir sind
nicht allein exklusiv-interview zu humor
und aliens hierbei klicks unbedingt
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren das
abonnieren geht ganz einfach mit dem
button unter dem video ich freue mich
über jede und jeden der oder die klicks
um folgt bis dann bleibt dran